[Music]
lindsay starts off this hour in salt
lake city utah hi lindsay how are you
hey you dave i'm excited to talk to you
you too how can we help
okay so i'm currently well my husband
and i are currently in baby step two we
make a hundred thousand together we
still have forty thousand
um left to go on our debt snowball but i
have a question about
uh when we get to
baby step three
how to invest her 15 percent so he has a
403 b i have a 401 k with a 3 match
and then i have a roth ira and a
traditional ira set up and then he has a
traditional ira wow and i guess i just
don't know how to
when we get there
how to giving it up
yeah you've got a lot going on here and
let me make sure i get this clear baby
step three is your three to six months
fully funded emergency fund
are you talking about baby step four
yes sorry okay well you're you're
dreaming you're you're definitely
thinking ahead here
so we can talk about what to do when you
get there uh are you guys on track to
pay this debt off in the coming year
yes so our goal is by this time next
year way to go awesome
that's fantastic and then what does
three to six months of expenses look
like for you guys
it would be about 10 to 12 grand okay do
you think you might be able to do all of
that in the next 12 months
um
we may need another so after a year
we'll be debt-free and then we'll need
six months that's your
emergency fund that's awesome so what
we're talking about right now is 18
months from now when you've got all of
this in place you've got no debt the
fully funded emergency fund how do we
invest this 15
in in the best way possible
yep okay
well it's going to be 15 of your total
household income and tell me again what
your options are um with your
his work and your work
yeah so he has a 403 b which as i
understand it is
basically a 401k
and then i have a 401k with a three
percent match i don't think he has a
match
and then i have a loss and a traditional
ira and then he has a traditional ira
because i did what dave said and i
rolled over all of our old 401ks into
um our own iras with a smartbuster pro
well obviously we're going to do 15 of
100 000 or 15 000 is how we've got to
allocate it and our formula is pretty
simple it's kind of like rock paper
scissors except you can only win one way
and so it's r match
beats roth
beats traditional so let's allocate the
15 000
down that list
until we do whatever now does his 401k
are sure your 401k right he's got a 403b
correct are either one of those a roth
option
yes i have a roth option on your 401k
okay so um what we'll do is put
certainly we're going to do the match so
we want to put in the match at this
point for three percent up to yours and
what do you make a year
i think 40.
okay
and so
okay and uh let's see here so three is
that 1200 bucks yeah 1200 bucks will be
your 3 match
off of the 15 000 okay
so match beats roth that's the only
match we got so we're gonna do that
first okay so off of the off of that so
we've got 13 eight we still got to go
with does that sound right
yep okay and then we're going to do roth
anywhere there's roth that we want to do
it
so his 403b does not have a roth so
we're not going over there that's
traditional we're going to use your 401k
and we're going to use two roth
individual iras
and see if we can get to 13 8 and by the
way we know we can
because two roth iras get you there more
than get you there so we need 13 800
going into something
uh and and you can use your 401k does
your 401k have really good mutual fund
options
so i actually just started um so i'm not
really sure and since we're on the debt
snowball i am not investing anything so
i'm not really sure okay well and uh i'm
gonna guess and say you can do six
thousand dollars into your roths uh two
individual roth iras and good growth
stock mutual funds with a smartvestor
pro okay
that gets us to twelve thousand uh and
so you could put another couple thousand
in yours and eighteen hundred and you'll
be to your fifteen thousand so we'll
probably utilize your 401k through the
match plus 2 000 a year and then we'll
do a couple of roth iras maxed out with
your smartvestor pro and you will have
done match beats roth we never got to
traditional so we'll do nothing in this
403b which by the way generally speaking
your 401ks will have probably better
options than a lot of 403bs will for
investing in terms of the quality of the
mutual funds
okay interesting cool that is very
helpful thank you so much and you know
how old are you
so i just turned 31. ah you're going to
be a millionaire
no you really are
that's what the math says
i mean you start putting 15 000
a year away
in roth
in mutual funds you're going to be a
millionaire so fast girl i'm so proud of
you and their incomes are only going to
go up yeah that's that's if they don't
get a raise yeah man you'd have to be
real bad at your job to never get a
raise in your entire career
so this bodes well
that's awesome and i i do the full 15 in
our roth 401k here dave because we've
got some great options
and both of you work here yeah so you me
and my wife yeah you can both it's great
yeah so we're gonna be double
millionaires yeah that's how that works
right
i'm in i'm in i mean a 2 millionaire a 3
millionaire i like the sound of that 4
millionaire double triple quadruple
that's awesome i love that she's asking
this stuff now because a lot of people
they're in debt but to dream about the
future and what could be and what you
want to be investing and how much that
could turn into i love that because it
only motivates the debt snowball it only
motivates you through baby step three
which can be a slog exactly so here's
the reason for our order there it's math
okay match you get a 100 rate of return
before the mutual fund starts doing
anything not bad you made 100
now you do have to pay taxes on that
match when you take it out
but after taxes you still got a 70 rate
of return or an 80 rate of return on
your money excellent you can't beat that
tax-free doesn't beat that but tax-free
beats taxable
so roth beats traditional
and so you've in her case she's got the
match and then she's got tax-free growth
on everything else so their entire
account is going to end up being the
vast majority of their account not the
entire account because the match isn't
but the vast majority of their account
will be in that roth and covered under
the roth legislation and so it will all
be tax-free amazing so if it says 2
million and that roth portion you get 2
million